alain marsaud ancien député ancien
magistrat ancien chef du service central
de lutte antiterroriste alain marsaud
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france on se souvient des mots du
président emmanuel macron au lendemain
de l'attentât de samuel pâtit ils ne
passeront pas ils sont toujours là ils
sont passés pour vous à la marceau on se
souvient de tellement de mots de
tellement de président de la république
qui nous ont expliqué que on allait voir
ce qu'on allait voir hélas ça continue
de s'aggraver de la ferme et rahan de
picasa aujourd'hui à notre entendement
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que l'on
fasse aujourd'hui nous sommes tout
simplement soumis à une bière qui vous
émeut les personnes a envie de
reconnaître ce que personne n'a envie
vient tout simplement de riposter aux
deux premiers mesures qui s'imposent
je vous rappelle quand même que il ya en
qu'en 2017 le candidat macro n'était que
candidat a été déclaré a jugé que la
colonisation en algérie était un crime
contre l'humanité ensuite nous avons
notre ambassadeur en suède il ya
toujours de cela un dénommé tiennent de
koné ville qui vient de déclarer
division suédoise
la france est un pays musulman dans un
train mais on va t'on va te reste avant
cet ambassadeur a été rappelé qu'il a
été sanctionné
visiblement pas donc je comprends
qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans de france
triste estiment qu'ils ont des droits et
certains les feront valoir écrire avec
tant la violence dans la plus extrême
violence pour là où nous en sommes nous
sommes un pays
comment dirais-je nous sommes en pays
qui recule qui recule le jour après jour
devant l'ot francisci m e des samistes
il faut bien se dire une chose c'est que
l'islam
beaucoup de contenus jugement là dessus
mais l'islam est une religion de
conquête alors saisir une région de
conquête il faut savoir si effectivement
en face de sept de ses réalités de
conquête
nous français nous sommes capables de
riposter au nord c'est une région de
conquête et je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous
savez c'est finalement 30 ans de lâcheté
de naïveté et de compromissions de la
part de tous les régimes
alain marsaud n'était alain marsaud à ce
qu est ce que vous rejoignez les propos
d'eric ciotti le député les républicains
des alpes maritimes qui le dit je cite
notre pays est en guerre nous sommes en
guerre c'est le cas pour vous aussi
oui alors qu'il a fait mais je souhaite
y pensera monsieur ciotti
des déclarations que je sais qu'il a
soutenu l'idée majorité qui n'ont rien
fait écoutez nous avons nous avons
trente ans nous avons trente ans de
lâcheté de compromission et daïf t
est-ce qu'on va continuer pourquoi pas
60e compte il n'y a plus rien à faire
croire que c'est trop tard véritable
ensuite le code tout à fait désespérer
on sait plus la peine d'écouter les
politiques qui nous font des
déclarations on va voir ce qu'on va voir
qu'elle a effectivement on ne voit rien
il ne se passe rien et ils ne sont pas
prêts à prendre les bonnes décisions
alors est ce qu'il existe encore de
bonnes décisions parce que au fond
aujourd'hui l'islam et l'islamisme ce
qui est une déviation entre guy hoquet
flammes
il s'installe en france définitivement
le tout est de savoir quand on va se
mettre mettre en place une partition
samedi par et le reste des gens qui nous
ont pas qui ne sont pas musulmans
alors certes ce que l'on a fait de la
france fait prom temps de composition de
naïveté et de l'acheter alors cette
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
aujourd'hui elle doit passer par ont
pour le part nulle part jacques vabre
avons aujourd'hui une base tellement
importante de d'individus prêts à passer
à l'action
vous avez tout simplement un communiqué
qui a été acquis des lieux croix du dan
son de l'agent stabat la vente à batz et
comment dirais-je lagence officieuse
d'al qaïda qui dit maintenant vous les
musulmans de france passer à l'action
quitter français en france étudie
français aussi à l'étranger s'est passé
depuis quelques jours ces gens leur sont
offertes l'action donc aujourd'hui on
ait un ce même pas une main et transiger
particulière de l'histoire qui a décidé
de nous faire la guerre et nous en face
de cela aussi je vous rappelle que nous
sommes le seul pays européen à subir
tout ça on a tous le droit aux qu'ovide
avec notre capacité ou non d'y répondre
et par contre en ce qui concerne le
terrorisme d'inspiration islamiste
nous sommes les seuls à le subir
cherchez l'erreur nous avons encouragé
nous avons encouragé de vos dix pendant
30 ans de l'acheter et bien voilà nous
le payons aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
n'ya plus rien à faire et j'ai pas la
peine clients de grands discours
on va voir ce qu'on va voir et alain
marsaud vous vous êtes ancien magistrat
sur le plan judiciaire du service
entendu tanti tourist en l'espace de
trois ans sous monsieur pasqua et
monsieur challenge avions nous avions
mis fin à toutes les actions terroristes
sur le territoire français nous direz
c'est être un peu fait remplacer
complètement potache anthony 286
épitaphe 88 et quelle était la
différence avec aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que vous faisiez justement par 12 en
huit le terrorisme ab à l'époque
d'abord il ya une volonté politique
d'abord les acteurs n'était pas adam
adach qu un dark politique c'était le
fln j'ai effectué le hezbollah et les
iraniens
donc je voulais donc de zabga ça n'était
pas tout à fait les mêmes
nous avons agi avec les services
d'enseignement et prairies ta volonté
politique nous avons créé le sari
central de lutte antiterroriste que j'ai
eu l'honneur et dirigé et avec cet outil
de centralisation
nous avons réussi à éradiquer tous les
terrorismes en france maintenant mon
avis n'est plus possible parce que les
acteurs sont tellement plus nombreux
tellement plus j'ai pas du tout
simplement parce qu'il n'existe pas de
véritable volonté de lutter on a
beaucoup entendu les propos de monsieur
sushis et autres en étant guerre est
alors monsieur sutil a il a pris une
cote de maille il est parti il est parti
avec un pistolet mitrailleur pour aller
pour faire sa guerre non j'ai fait moi
j'en ai marre des mots jamais râlé marre
de tous ces politiques qui devraient pas
dire qu'on est en guerre et qu'ils ne
font rien qui restent assis sur leurs qu
au delà des mots 7000 militaires
déployés au
de 3000 oui voyez passer de 1000
militaires
ils ont surveillé les marques et ils
vont protéger le masquer ils vont
protéger les églises pour éviter qu'on a
le côté gauche des curés je vous
rappelle qu'on a aussi égorgée à 3,7 en
2007 inspiré et quelques jours deux
personnes dans une église
et depuis lors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on commence aujourd'hui a dit croyez pas
que c'est la marque véritablement d'un
échec un échec de la france et pas la
république c'est la france qui est un
échec
on vous sent en colère ce soit en colère
contre le mans l'inaction des politiques
à l'acheter là c'est pas une action
qu'il a acheté les compromissions
regarder nous avons des maires et des
équipes qui si pâle qui aujourd'hui ont
tout fait pour acheter les voix des des
islamistes de bien de se constituer et
était à la la constitution
d'associations etc etc
mais ces compromissions sont
terrifiantes quand on en fera le bilan
et hors bilan
j'espère que ces gens veulent bien de
répondre au nom de la responsabilité de
tout ça je suis je suis totalement guéri
il n'y a plus rien à faire il n'y a plus
rien à faire c'est aussi la france
voulait se montrer courageuse mais
finalement la france d'aujourd'hui c'est
la force de me la fin car voilà merci
alain marsaud d'avoir répondu à nos
capés que vous êtes ancien député ancien
magistrat ancien chef du service central
de lutte antiterroriste